الى مجلس الامن حيث سجال سياسي يعكس
الانقسام والاستقطاب العالمي بشان حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا فالمجلس ومعه منظومه
الامم المتحده لم ينجح في منع اندلاع
الحرب او وقفها اعضاء المجلس خصوصا اصحاب
العضويه الدائمه معنيون بالحرب بشكل او
باخر حتى الصين التي تطرح اليوم وثيقه
للحل السياسي تواجه اتهامات من قبل الناتو
بعزمها تزويد موسكو بمساعدات عسكريه
اذا انعقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه خاصه
على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه لدول الاعضاء
لمناسبه مرور عام على حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وتحفظ المندوب الروسي في المجلس
غسيل اليبنزا على عقد جلسه بشان اوكرانيا
واعطاء وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني الكلمه
قبل اعضاء مجلس الامن مضيفا انه يجب عدم
اعطاء اوكرانيا امتيازات على حساب روسيا
في جلسه المجلس وقال المدوب الروسي ان
الغرب يسعى لتحويل مجلس الامن الى اداه
خاصه به حسب تعبيره
وخلال جلسه مجلس الامن دعى وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا الى انشاء محكمه دوليه خاصه
بما وصفه بجريمه العدوان على اوكرانيا
ندعو لانشاء محكمه ذات ولايه قضائيه خاصه
بجريمه العدوان على اوكرانيا تكون قادره
على محاسبه ذوي الحصانه ولا سيما
المسؤولين الرئيسيين عن هذه الجريمه
وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان اي سلام
يطفى الشرعيه على استيلاء روسيا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالقوه سيضعف ميثاق
الامم المتحده اضاف في كلمه له امام جلسه
لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان اوكرانيا ان
الرئيس الروسي بدا الحرب على اوكرانيا وهو
من يمكنه انهائها حسب تعبيره
كل سلام يضفي الشرعيه على استيلاء روسيا
على الارض بالقوه سيضعف الميثاق وسيبعث
رساله الى المعتدين المحتملين في كل مكان
بانه يمكنهم غزو البلدان والافلات من
العقاب لا ينبغي لاي عضو في هذا المجلس ان
يدعو الى السلام بينما يدعم حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وعلى ميثاق الامم المتحده في هذه
الحرب هناك معتدل وضحيه روسيا تحارب من
اجل الاحتلال واوكرانيا تحارب من اجل
حريتها اذا توقفت روسيا عن القتال وغادرت
اوكرانيا ستنتهي الحرب واذا توقفت
اوكرانيا عن القتال فستنتهي اوكرانيا تبقى
الحقيقه هي ان رجلا واحدا هو فلاديمير
بوتين بدا الحرب وهو الذي يمكنه انهائها
في المقابل قال المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس
الامن فاسيلي نيبنزيا ان بلاده مستعده
للتفاوض بشان كيفيه تنفيذ اهداف عملياتها
العسكريه باستخدام الوسائل السلميه لكنها
غير مستعده للنظر في السيناريوهات التي لا
تتحقق فيها تلك الاهداف كما قال المندوب
الروسي ان روسيا لم تعلن ان هدفها من
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو تدمير
اوكرانيا وان انهاء اوكرانيا للاعمال
العدائيه سيتيح لها فرصه ان تكون دوله
طبيعيه وفق تعبيره
بدوره قال مندوب الصين بمجلس الامن ان
الحلول الدبلوماسيه هي السبيل الوحيد لحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه وان وضع اطراف النزاع
حول طاوله المفاوضات ليس امرا سهلا لكنه
الخطوه الاولى نحو حل سياسي مشيرا الى انه
يجب التفكير في وقف القتال والوصول الى
سلام في اوكرانيا واوروبا وفق تعبيره كما
قال المندوب الصيني انه من الضروري عدم
اجتياز الخط الاحمر المتعلق بالسلاح
النووي